étudier cette prairie afin de s'assurer
du développement de la biodiversité
locale
voilà une démission d'olivier marchal
chargé d'études au parc régional de la
haute vallée de chevreuse nous le
retrouvons aujourd'hui sur l'un des
sites d'intérêt écologique les plus
riches du parc où sont fréquemment
effectuer des suivis afin de rendre
compte de l'état de santé de ces espaces
donc là on se trouve sur la commune de
saint lambert des bois on met sur
l'après la gravelle qui nous prairies
qui appartient au parc naturel régional
et on est venu en fait sur la partie
basse de la prairie
voir où en était un certain nombre de
plantes rares qui poussent ici
principalement vous voulez aller voir
les stations de l'hymne aigrettes
c'est une petite plante en fait qui va
pousser dans les tourbières et dans les
prairies tour buzz comme on a ici et qui
est une espèce qui est protégé et qu'on
suit un peu régulièrement voir oui si
elle se maintient bien l'enjeu c'est de
voir si globalement en termes de
biodiversité sur le parc on n'a pas une
perte si ces espèces très rares il
arrive à se maintenir
et en plus ici on est sur une prairie
qui est gérée par le parc
l'idée c'est aussi d'adapter la gestion
quand on pratique une gestion qui depuis
presque 20 ans permet à la prairie de la
gravelle de ne pas s'en fiche et malgré
l'abandon du pâturage par l'agriculture
dans les années 60
outre la flore la faune est aussi
préservé par l'entretien de ces espaces
et offre ainsi de beaux foyer à ses
habitants associés à ces groupements de
plantes on va avoir beaucoup de
d'espèces d'animaux aussi qu'ils sont
assez remarquables notamment des
insectes beaucoup d'insectes donc
aujourd'hui on a pu dans la plus
observée le nacre et de la sanguisorbe
qu'un papillon qui vit sur la reine des
prés sur une plante typique de ces
prairies humides c'est vraiment un enjeu
fort du parc de rouvrir ses prêts aux
limites dans les fonds de vallée pour la
faune pour la flore pour les paysages
aussi puisque ça ça ouvre des
perspectives des vues sur le sur le
paysage et puis c'est un rôle aussi à
jouer sur le maintien d'une agriculture
dans le parc de nombreuses raisons qui
expliquent donc les suivi régulier de 12
sites représentant une superficie de 60
hectares d'espacés naturels au sein de
la vallée de chevreuse